[Musik]
sie ist eine gesellschaftliche position
als kleinbauer in sambia ist gut
[Musik]
akzeptieren die leute bei dem dorf den
einsatz von pflanzenschutzmitteln und
dünger
reicht dir dann einkommen was du aus
deiner farm generieren kannst um deine
familie zu ernähren
[Musik]
respekt ich glaub sank im september in
der folge september so emotionen
du hast du hast du den wunsch dass eines
seiner kinder deine farm später mal
übernehmen wird
was ist deine motivation bei race to the
world mitzumachen
in den kita in sambia in den bahnhof st
warum muss die claims an futur ii so 16
[Musik]
training die stadt gut in st
die uni china nur in alba fingern ist
wie gut du gast bei 1 am fuß den
kabarett den ist das inferno des grauens
bot die mini fortschritten und julius
und china
[Musik]
die heilpraktische nutzen ausschließlich
traktoren aber gar nicht mehr sagt
bestimmen
60 70 80 jahren gibt es hier keine
option mehr zur feldarbeit
[Musik]
die disko inseln der profi traders im
ackerbau oder im hauptbetrieb verteilen
da alles mit der maschine bei den
blumenfeldern ist es in der tat so dass
wir auf kleinen flächen auch noch mit
der dinge wanner mit der schüssel
überlaufen dass brand verteilen die
fläche ist viel zu groß und das mit der
hand bewältigen zu können haben die das
früher auch mit der hand gemacht da
waren aber unzählige arbeitskräfte auf
den flächen unterwegs die wir heute mit
ganz wenig personal zu erwirtschaften
und zum zweiten sind die lohnkosten hier
in unseren breiten so hoch dass das gar
nicht funktionieren würde
[Musik]
die idee sehr blutig minto jetzt die
d-junioren nein an die regierung ganz
klar nein die das ist kein käufer von
getreide oder zuckerrüben
wir verkaufen an private firmen wie zb
die südzucker ag wie getreidehändler
hier vor ort wie mühlen wie man sein
haus und fast jeder hat ein eigenes
gemacht also im sommer sind wir ganz oft
auch ein trampolin in sebring tag sind
wir meistens friends
[Musik]
bei der 26 27 aus dem haus und fahren
bus zur schule
also ich habe es cool reichhaltig in der
schule war und hat sich damit auch
größer gefüllt und ein kiss rückenschule
cool
[Musik]